chris is with us in Connecticut hi Chris
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
it's an honor thanks for having me sure
what's up that last rant was a good
lead-in for my question I need help from
mean old Uncle Dave to help articulate
the craziness of a family members
actions we have a family member who
wants to go to grad school out of state
for $60,000 a year plus living expenses
and started a GoFundMe page to raise the
money they have undergrad loans still
they live at home they work full-time
and in their post they address the
questions of why don't you choose a
state school or a cheaper school and
said those programs are too competitive
and if one school accepts you you go no
matter what because you will never have
another opportunity and they say they do
not approve of working or it's
discouraged by the school for fear of
failing out we love this person but
there's so much wrong with this that I
don't know where to start the
conversation and I know what to say but
I know you'll say it better why are you
going to start the conversation because
I mean that we don't want her to start
out her life in in debt and in paying
off her loans in 20 years I mean knowing
what I know I wish I knew it at her age
yeah we want to help okay hey this
doesn't sound like someone that is going
to be persuaded to me mm-hmm
that's why I asked um I think that this
is an arrogant person who's got
everything figured out no she really
isn't she is normally a very sweet girl
and this kind of took the whole family
by surprise and the whole family's
pretty upset about it but no one really
knows what to say how old was a girl I
think she's 23 okay and what relation is
she do you like cousin your wife's
cousin that's fairly distant it's not
like it's you're all pretty close that's
not like it's your sister okay well I
don't think you've
not much of a footing to do a persuasion
'el talk here but if you were going to
you just have to rebut the stupid stuff
that she's saying mm-hmm I mean you just
have to go through and go this is just
simply not true okay the idea that you
have to go to this school to be
competitive is not true the idea that
you have to go to school that requires
you to not work is not true what is the
field of study nurse practitioner okay
they do generally require our encourage
you to not work in that field of study
when you're doing your final your even
when you're doing your grad work because
that is very intense so it's a wonderful
field and 60 grams not bad
only she just never can in her pain
offer her undergrad law no I'd be fine
if she called me if she could figure out
a way to go for cash I'd go for cash and
while the undergrads at until she gets
out and finishes her nurse practitioner
then use that income to clear up the
undergrad I wouldn't want to add to the
hole that she's in but this here's the
thing anytime someone in making any
decision I mean virtually any decision
says there's only one way to do this
that type of fatalism is flawed logic
mmm-hmm it's the same thing same logic
that says oh there's only one person on
the planet I was supposed to marry and
that one got away
I will never get married no no there's
more than one if you can choose from
there's only one house you know I only
have two jobs I can choose from though
there's a whole lot of jobs you can
choose from you know I mean anytime you
narrow your choices down and create a
drama around the fact that you made the
choice says that your critical thinking
skills are broken does that make sense
yeah it does you know and so that that's
where I would attack this and just go
you know it's kind of almost a pat on
the head and just say calm down sweetie
there's other ways to become a nurse
practitioner this is not the only school
to go to it's not the only one you can
get accepted to and there's other ways
to fund going you know and so what
you're doing is trying to create your
ideal world here where you don't have
consequences and get to do whatever the
flip you want to do and no one is liking
this we're all looking at you thinking
it's stupid
we think the emperor has no clothes and
I'm gonna be the kid in the street that
says dudes naked I'm gonna call you out
and say this is bad logic it's bad for
you it makes you look dumb and immature
and you're not dumb and immature but you
really are acting it and there's other
ways to become a nurse practitioner than
this school it's not the only school on
the planet the lever except you what a
load of horse crap you know lots of
people work and do other things I don't
do much while they're in nurse
practitioner school but it's very tough
to get through it's a tough four it's a
rigorous study program it really is it's
not it's not one that it's easy to do to
work but she already got her under guard
he got her nursing certificate and she
just wants to go to a nurse practitioner
level I don't know exactly what her
undergrad was in but she's working as a
medical assistant right now I mean she
could pass her nursing bar ahead of time
and go ahead and be a nurse she could
probably do some practicum stuff and get
paid for it while she's doing this she
might even get a hospital company to
write the check and take her to nursing
practitioner if she agreed to work for
him for a few years and go you know that
that's a way to get the things
scholarship there's all kinds of ways to
look at this and once you decide that
fatalism is not your methodology for
your critical thinking skills meaning I
go into drama mode and go there's only
one ready to do this this is the way and
you're telling me I can't live my dreams
that's just so immature mm-hmm it's just
so would you recommend with you know in
that being my wife's side of the family
that my wife take the lead on this
instead of whoever has enough
credibility with her because you're
telling someone you love something that
they likely are not going to hear and
the only way they might hear it is if
they truly believe the person delivering
it loves them mm-hmm deeply I mean
because you know you think about
somebody delivering you news you don't
want to hear who are you going to hear
it from someone you really trust and
that you trust that they don't have a
conflict of interest and you trust their
wisdom and you
the fact that they care about your life
that's who you'll hear wicked tough news
from right yeah I mean cuz that's why
you know somebody in you know New
Hampshire sends me hate mail about
something I said I'm just like that's
humorous you know or you troll me on
Twitter that's just humorous because the
likelihood of me changing my behavior
being accountable to one of you that
I've never met is just a mean but I'm
not going to but one of my best friends
walks in here who's written five
best-selling books and goes Dave's what
you saw on radio that they was really
you were off base on that I'm gonna hear
that from that guy right yeah he can
deliver me cuz in other words if you're
gonna smack somebody in the back of the
head you first got to get your arm
around their shoulder mm-hmm and give
them a hug so your hand is in position
to smack the back of the head well you
know you said something the other day on
the show about you know someone who's
doing something not smart and everyone
else is saying oh yeah that's great good
for you and behind your back they're
saying you know now's dumb well just
tell them just tell them that so you
know people are talking about you behind
your back bounce dude but this isn't no
one's got no one loves you enough Scott
enough courage to sit down and look at
you and say hey I really want to
challenge some of your logic here
because I don't think it's good for you
it doesn't affect me it doesn't affect
me you go do this my life is not gonna
change because I'm not giving you any
money and I'm not gonna pay any of your
debt so it doesn't affect me at all I
just care about you and I think you've
got some flawed logic here and I think
this lack of wisdom is going to bring
pain into your life and I'm gonna love
you enough to tell you when maybe
someone else didn't that's your only way
to set this up and it is probably your
wife not you but even then I think this
girl is so invested in this path
emotionally that it's gonna be she's not
asking you know yeah she's not asking
she's telling everybody I said arrogant
she's not asking for advice she's
telling everyone this is the way it is
you people mm-hmm and that's why I don't
think she's gonna listen that my
grandmother used to say those convinced
against their will or of the same
opinions still so that's why I don't
argue with people on the show I answer
your question you know you hear me call
people call in and they asked me the
same question four times after
I've already answered it trying to get a
different answer that they want you ever
heard that yeah I finally just hang up
on cuz I'm wasting my time they didn't
want to answer they want me to prove
they're stupid today and I'm not going
to and I move on to the next caller so
hey I appreciate that you care about
your cousin you're a good man your
wife's cousin it's a good thing
it'sit's hard to watch people you love
do stupid stuff and embarrassing things
and most all of us have a family member
or two that too but if you know your
wife can try it that way man I just can
give you a low probability success I
think those girls already got her mind
made up